c'est en 1961 souvenez vous il ya
presque 20 ans que jacques mesrine
commençait sa carrière de gangsters si
je puis dire vingt années de meurtre de
cavale de hold up qui avait fait de cet
homme de 36 ans un bandit vraiment pas
comme les autres c'est en mars 1962 à 26
ans que jacques mesrine fait son entrée
dans les annales judiciaires pour un
banal cambriolage qui lui vaut 18 mois
de prison
une fois libéré il retournera bientôt à
la délinquance avec des ambitions
décuplées hold-up pillage d'appartements
et braquages dans les banques premier
règlement de comptes
mesrine dira lui même qu'il est devenu
un tueur sans remords et sans regret
traquée en france ils courent sa chance
au canada après une courte tentative de
retour au travail honnête il enlève son
ancien employeur il n'arrivera pas à
toucher la rançon à cause de la
défaillance d'un complice mais le voilà
hisser parmi les grands du banditisme
international
il est pourtant arrêté deux ans plus
tard en 71 alors nouveau coup d'éclat il
réussit à s'évader de la prison de haute
sécurité de montréal avec cinq autres
détenus
puis il pousse l'audace jusqu'à attaquer
ce même pénitencier les armes à la main
pour tenter de libérer les amis qu'il
s'y était fait c'est un échec mais après
cette action sans précédent
le cas mesrine est posé il n'est pas un
truand ordinaire septembre 72,2
garde-chasse ont tué dans la forêt
québécoise ce sont les deux seuls
meurtre officiellement attribué à misery
il rentre en france ou en mars 73 il est
arrêté on ne le gardera que trois mois
il avait préparé d'avancé les moyens de
son évasion des armes cachées au palais
de justice de compiègne lui permettent
de prendre en otage le président du
tribunal
il réussit à s'enfuir il est maintenant
l'ennemi public numéro trois mois de
liberté seulement le 28 septembre 73 la
brigade antigang le cueille au gîte à
paris il offre le champagnes commissaire
broussard une des rares personnes qu'il
dit respecter et qu'il désigne
volontiers comme un grand flic pendant
la langue d'instruction de son procès
trois ans et demi il écrit un livre
l'instinct de mort où il revendique 39
meurtre alors même qui n'est pas encore
jugé
roh succès de vente la justice est
bloqué les droits d'auteur plus de 500
mille francs au total 19 mai 1977
jacques mesrine est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle après un procès de
quatorze jours le voilà à la santé la
prison dont on ne s'évade pas il est
placé dans un cul hs quartier de haute
sécurité
réservé aux grands criminels réputé
dangereux oui mais tout un an seulement
le 8 mai soixante dix huit la prison de
la santé vers sa réputation
mesrine s'évade des qhs avec son ami
françois bès un troisième compagnon
d'évasion karmann rive est tué sur place
au coin de la rue de la santé nous avait
la casquette et puis elle cette espèce
de blousons quand comme les matons
pareil je discute avec la violence m'a
dit qu'on voit que je reviens de loin le
plus nombreux comme ça placerait mesrine
des armes et tout matériel avait été
cachée dans le parloir du cul hs mesrine
a donc bénéficié de complicités
multiples
dix jours plus tard hold up au casino de
deauville mesrine est blessé d'une balle
à la hanche en juin ils vident la caisse
de la société générale au raincy il
avait d'abord pris en otage chez lui à
son domicile
le fondé de pouvoir et l'avait contraint
à l'accompagner jusqu'à la banque nous a
dit qu'ils voulaient pas le cas nous les
poser malkin mais simplement de l'argent
mais pas d'ici ni à nous novembre 78
prise d'otage manquer chez monsieur
petit président de la cour d'assises de
paris
c'est pour protester contre l'existence
des quartiers de haute sécurité dans les
prisons où l'on transforme dit il des
hommes en faut en juin enlèvement
d'henri lelièvre l'octogénaire
milliardaire de la sarthe
mesrine le libère le 28 juillet contre
une rançon de 6 millions il a désormais
les poches pleines
un autre en profiterait pour tenter de
disparaître pas lui
le 10 septembre 79 il accepte un rendez
vous avec jacques tillier journaliste à
minute près de creil dans une carrière
désaffectée il le bleis de trois balles
il écrit aux journaux j'ai voulu punir
tillier par ses écrits par ces messages
ou ces menaces aux journaux les
interviews données
ces déclarations lors de son procès il a
veillé à construire son personnage à
nourrir sa légende
mais saura-t-on jamais leur sort secret
de cette vie errante courageux sans
doute mais bâti sur le crime et en
définitive gâcher une réponse est
peut-être donné par le titre du récit
qu'il en a fait l'instinct de mort